bonjour à thème nafti merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous ce matin dans la
matinale de rtl france alors on a vu
cette
tentative en tout cas puisque le conseil
de la magistrature a refusé d'être
dissolue pourquoi pourquoi cette cette
dissolution décrété par le président
alors il faut savoir que on est dans une
logique qui a commencé le 25 juillet qui
se poursuit le président aissa sarrail
des tentera de
mettre entre ses mains et d'abattre
pardon tous les contre-pouvoirs qui sont
qui était pendant qu'ils se dressaient
contre lui donc ce à commencer par le
parlement le gouvernement
on a eu l'instance de la lutte contre la
corruption qui est fermé depuis des mois
alors que paradoxalement il dit lutter
contre 1 contre la corruption il s'est
attribué les pleins pouvoirs le 22
septembre et le seul si vous voulez
contre-pouvoir institutionnel qui lui
restent sont assez le conseil supérieur
de la magistrature et l'instar des
élections et il a commencé déjà dans ses
discours à s'attaquer à l'instance des
élections donc là on va clairement vers
un concentration des pouvoirs aux mains
d'un seul homme et ses reprises s'arrête
et donc ça fait des mois qu'ils disaient
fakih l'attaqué sans cesse le conseil il
parlait de purifier la justice et y
jouer sur l'ambiguïté que qui ne lui
échappe à étant donné qu'il est
professeur de droit il a créé dans
l'opinion publique cette idée que
c'était le conseil supérieur de la
majorité de la magistrature qui jugeait
et le fait que ça intervienne le 6
février donc le jour de la commémoration
de l'assassinât de chokri de l'arrivée
live voilà c'était aussi dans ce sens
c'est à dire que les tunisiens exigent
et à raison je pense l'obtention de la
de la réalité sauf que ce n'est pas le
conseil supérieur de la magistrature qui
juge ce sont des magistrats dans leur
tribune long mais ça fait neuf ans
c'était une bande oui effectivement
alors d'une part on peut entendre
l'argument qui dit ça fait plus ça fait
plus de 50 hommes de 60 ans que kennedy
est mort on sait toujours pas qui l'a
assassiné
l'autre côté il ya eu de véritables
dysfonctionnements couvert par de très
hauts magistrats donc ça c'est quelque
chose qui est vrai en revanche
ce n'est encore encore une fois ce n'est
pas le conseil supérieur de la
magistrature qui jugent de cela même si
c'est mon très permissif avec un certain
nombre de hauts magistrats donc le
président s'est saisie de cette de cette
opportunité de la colère des tunisiens
pour pour décréter ça mais en réalité
c'est un autre contre-pouvoir qu'il est
en train d'abattre alors les juges
effectivement sont en charge de cette
affaire mais le vol au président dit que
le conseil de la magistrature aurait
ralenti en tout cas la procédure en
couvrant notamment des dirigeants du
parti islamiste ennahda est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec ça alors que le
conseil soit directement intervenu dans
sa moi j'aimerais bien qu'ils donnent
qui donne des éléments après il ya eu
des magistrats qui siégeait au conseil
supérieur de la magistrature ex qualité
notamment le procureur de la république
de tunis en charge des affaires de
terrorisme et le président de la cour de
cassation qui aujourd'hui sont suspendus
et poursuivi l'unfp pour
l'un dans le cadre de la sphère enfin
d'affaires de corruption et l'autre en
lien avec ce sujet ont effectivement
reproche à l'ancien procureur qui était
aussi juge d'instruction dans cette même
affaire d'avoir d'avoir à travailler les
choses ce qui s'est passé c'est que la
semaine dernière le tribunal enfin la
cour d'appel administrative a annulé la
suspension prononcée par le conseil
supérieur de la magistrature contre l'un
de ces magistrats et donc à une
véritable colère populaire sur laquelle
assure c'est le président de la
république pour rendre pour rendre
populaire cette décision est une partie
des tunisiens en tout cas on applaudit
le cette décision de dissoudre le
conseil supérieur de la magistrature
oui parce que d'un côté je pense que
personne estime qu'il n'y a pas de
problème avec la machine judiciaire en
tunisie il ya effectivement des
problèmes
il y a comme je vous ai dit une opinion
publique qui travaillait depuis des mois
en lui expliquant que les problème de la
justice ce n'est que le conseil
supérieur de la magistrature
et après quand vous dites les tunisiens
je ne sais pas dans quel pourcentage le
tunisien lambda à un avis un avis
tranché sur ça mais par contre
effectivement et tout un travail de
propagande menée notamment par le
président de la république pour dire si
vous avez des problèmes c'est à cause
d'eux du conseil supérieur de la
magistrature moi je ne pense pas que en
enlevant enfin en tout cas en enlevant
l'indépendance parce qu'ils étaient la
garantie donnée par le conseil supérieur
de la magistrature et en faisant des
juges
à la main ou à la botte du pouvoir qu'on
va résoudre quoi que ce soit pendant 60
ans c'était le cas sous bourguiba et ben
ali de à ma connaissance la justice
n'était pas très opérante est ce que
c'est une manoeuvre politique pour s'en
prendre au parti justement islamiste
ennahda entre autres je pense que le
président ne vise pas particulièrement
dans le président vise tout
contre-pouvoir effectivement l'un des
partis même s'il est affaiblie
aujourd'hui l'un des partis les plus
importants tunisie c'est le parti
islamiste mais ça va au delà de ça le
président et contre toute personne qui
émettrait la moindre critique
à son action il veut des voeux des
personnes en garde à vous il a rappelé
dans son discours de samedi en disant on
maintenant c'est qu'ils sont les
personnes sincères et qui sont les
opportunistes en étant entendu que les
opportunistes sont les personnes qui
l'ont soutenu après le 25 juillet et qui
commence à émettre des réserves quant à
sur l'action merci beaucoup à thème
nafti d'avoir répondu ce matin en direct
à nos questions sur rt france merci